hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the frozen north
right now we're we're like right outside
another landmark over here so we're
gonna go up and see where it is and what
horrors unfold for us when we go to that
place that we're going now bla bla bla
words words words that's death where am
I supposed to be down there
I highly doubt that I'm supposed to jump
off to my death now I've done some
stupid things in this game and I've done
some stupid things in my life jumping
off of many stupid other things like one
time when I was a kid I broke my arm
because we were having a how far out the
monkey bars contest you know how far out
can you jump contest I can't word good
I'm gonna hit my brain on the way down
speaking of hitting my brain when I was
even younger I had a context with my
brother the how far up the stairs can
you jump off contest then I whacked my
head into a post board saying corner you
know I can't think of words cuz you know
I hit my head so much as a child these
are true stories by the way I'm not even
joking
I really did whack my head and break my
arm having how far off can you jump god
s
okay I guess it's time for me to stop
telling sores
well alright then this seems like a
bunker is this doing here am I even
going to be able to get in over here
also what the hell was this that's weird
okay impassable eh I'm
I'm more than a little confused is this
the prison I've been hearing so much
about crouched under you nope
okay so windy is all hell there another
way up maybe ooh ooh yes oh my god yes
yes yes yes oh god yes yes yes yes I
made it cool I mean around I knew I
could
I wasn't believe in myself the whole
time you know if you ever if you ever
feel like you're in doubting yourself
you don't know what you're doing to
shout yes to yourself a whole bunch
you'll really build up your confidence
is that a page I hear yes yes yes heard
some Elsa oh god damn it's over there
how am I gonna get through that teddy
sprinkles Oh what ah
teddy sprinkles got my hopes up for
nothing damn it
okay it's got to be another way
can all be blocked off so perfectly that
mr. can jump over here would have to
either okay perfect
we're not perfect depending on how much
this leads me into my own death for I do
that but a turn down the lovely sounds
of the environment because I can barely
hear myself hello oh I thought that was
a glowy okay yes please do you know what
we wanted to do we play goals
telekinesis telepathy group hype North s
causing mental and physical disorders
creating disintegrated space subjects
did not even handle a sample of the
radiation the ones that somehow survived
behaves as is possessed communicating
with us in different voices languages
that we could not even recognize then
all of them died one after another some
turned into rock and some into ashes
I remember one who levitated all his
limbs twisted and he froze like that
above the ground a long time has passed
but it still haunts me I remember it I
see it happening in front of me every
night did anyone survive they later told
me that no one did but I think one of
the subjects could have survived do you
have any idea what we have done my dear
Anton okay so Anton was leader of this
whole organizational project over here
or maybe he did it all intentionally
because he wanted oh this good that's
great
okay this funk funk was that the sound
of me [ __ ] bricks I'll save that for
later
our eyes end Oh woof my dear oh shut up
I'm spending my time in the Institute on
long walks in the park only here I can
find solace only in the shadows of the
trees my thoughts are peaceful when I
see how the Sun brushes the green leaves
and the wind covers my face in a gentle
warm blow the doctors say the worst is
behind me the breakdown was temporary
it's difficult for me to say what
triggered this state I know you'll never
forgive me for what I've done the
tragedy that I have contributed to shall
never find any justification nor
explanation I can only cover it up with
madness but I am aware that this is a
pathetic excuse and I'm not able to hide
behind it I take full responsibility for
what happened and I am prepared to be
punished
the doctors however say I will probably
not leave the Institute you must know I
would rather rot in prison a hundred
times for what I have done to you I have
to confess I tricked you I knew you
would never ever want to hear what I
have to say to you that is why I sent my
friend with this letter to your sister
and after a lot of persuasion she agreed
to read it to you too
I thank you from the bottom of my heart
for this I'm ending this letter I want
to bore you no more I love you and
believe that someday hopefully I will be
able to tell you all this
in person luckily my friend Anton is by
my side at all times he was the one that
went to your sister I hope this letter
finds you both well and in good health
way all the best Forever Yours Vitali
who's Anton it is it who's oh that was
not me Bobby
Oh God well I totally forgot that I was
in imminent danger
are you Anton okay I hope that was the
sound of a door opening and not closing
on me alright was well sound those
footsteps don't sound like my own that's
why it's freaking me out
open I'm gonna leave somebody stop me
time does not heal wounds
well that's cuz you died so much in
movies recent than that huh this truth
was pounded into me by pain cruelty and
lies stinky I learned from this I
remembered a you Anton
it nearly touched the essence of my
understanding becoming the revelation of
truth when they dragged me down the
corridor with my shattered bones when
they operated on me to observe the
misplacement of my organs when they put
the worst nightmares into my head when
they closed me up put me together again
and revived me over
/ to test the limits of my endurance and
when finally after so many years they
told me my wife was dead time does not
heal wounds ki dokie then that's cool
story and all but I got one last
landmark to visit and I can't wait do
that hmm this guy's fun
this guy's really fun so but I whoa hey
tree can heal a frisky with me but I
what I'm scratching my head about is
okay he was talking about his broken
bones who's he the guy that was
levitated and had all his limbs twisted
and then froze there what in the world
is going on here it's like such a it's
such a mysterious mystery I can't
penetrate its defenses as soon as it won
the world is going on so bizarre it's so
intriguing okay I probably owe Church
tell we're supposed to go it's a Russian
Orthodox Church okay I'll do my best but
I gotta go down the mountain
I mean I could jump well that'd be
ridiculous
that'd be redonkulous that'd be that'd
be the stupidest that me the dumb dump w
uh
either broken test my endurance [ __ ]
well see I said that was dumb what I
meant was that was really dumb and I had
to do it because I like to do the dumb
thing because these walkthroughs they
kill you they tell you what not to do
okay I'm gonna be right back I'll be
back when I'm actually somewhere should
be okay mom okay so we're back at the
bridge where I died there's my rotting
corpse freezing already and here comes
the music the next area that I'm going
so there really is only one other place
that I can go
here at page is a page of whistle
Oppidan it wasn't oh how was I supposed
to get up there oh yeah
gaya night strange sounds coming from
the forest did not let us sleep Oh No
it's hard to tell what it was it sounded
to me like someone was calling me but
the rest of the group said it had been
some kind of humming huh we will ask the
locals if we meet them again in the
morning everyone was a bit scared but
after breakfast our moods improved
we set off up the river the snow isn't
really that deep but it's wet and it
sticks to the skis so it's hard to move
we passed a couple of cliffs and after a
couple of metres the area became more
flat finally around 5:30 p.m. we stopped
to set up a camp it is our first night
under canvas we were very tired we tried
to prepare for tomorrow's walk but
hunger was stronger then exhaustion
overcame us we sat around the fireplace
and talked or rather whispered we were
afraid to speak louder because of the
surrounding atmosphere as if this place
was sacred or haunted at last we took
shelter in the tents somehow nobody
feels like sleeping we thought someone
was passing by on the trail nearby so
the boys went to check it out but there
was nobody there
maybe it was some animal again I can
hear the sounds from the forest great
you came to the exact place you needed
to go to job congratulations
or something can I get
I really hope I can but apparently I
cannot not damn it
well where am I supposed to go then
where am I
wait how did I get all of it oh god do I
gotta go oh I gotta go the other way
around because this place is impassable
this is another way around anyone wants
to tell me about I'll just be on my way
then I don't know where I'm gonna go now
because I got a circle back and I don't
know if I got to go absolutely the long
way around and if I do pretty sure I can
fast travel to like probably that camp
up there would be quicker to go down
that way through some caves I'll see
about that it really knows who knows it
all
strange map is outdated and full it's
covered in bullcrap so where was that
camp yeah I mean I'm only assuming that
this is a proper way that it wanted me
to go because otherwise I would be
sticking my head and do a bridge that
don't go nowhere
that ain't gonna be good for nobody oh
no what where am I where where where am
i I do this is a one-way road okay then
where the hell did this come from I
don't remember this where am I wherever
hell happened how in the hell did I get
to here uh-huh
god it's so easy to get lost so easy is
that death okay that's a cave but how
did I get to a cave system I need to go
west yes
all right so weird it's so easy to get
turned around everything looks the exact
same
everything is covered in snow black
Zenith that's a lie everything doesn't
look exactly the same everything is
actually quite unique depending on where
you go but that doesn't mean that it's
not impossible to get luck there's that
not wolf again you back off for me I
want nothing to do for you
you're a dirty doggie my walking into
the Black Forest again because it seemed
to get awfully black and
yeah
is it something
something by me okay
musta Mexican you
we're it's a little weird because
nothing's happening oh hello are you
doing here hello Oh
live corpses in Siberia was there a
top-secret facility where scientists
worked on reviving the dead yes several
elements would suggest it was his case I
know this I was there okay so this is
pretty much the same you guys can read
through there's a lot to read through
here and I definitely want to get to the
actual games
let me skim through it delivery trucks
refrigerator tucks weird things occur
transporting people one day and stopped
military's engineers total Graham would
have been in the facility dr. he give
eminent historian government paranormal
fairy tale Indian village contradicts
the inhabitants stories existing
documents shed light try correspondence
furthermore the author author writes I
do hope you will manage to do something
with them because the mountain is being
impatient and one alive is not enough
the military sends whoa God
what is going on what is happening here
what madness is this where am i how am i
over here how in the hell did I get over
there all right I guess this was a
shortcut to the long way around okay but
this means that there's obviously a path
here that curves all the way like oh oh
there it is oh my god there it is that's
oh hey hi there who are you either that
dead wife hello okay bye what are you
looking at oh hi oh that's not oh that's
all I need but that's not good
yeah orange glow that's not good am I
gonna die probably but that's not good I
just want to read ring I'm not good that
is yes I guess this way is as good as
any they all kind of curve around to the
same destination
so that orange cloud should I be worried
about that at all ship Chuck Jack what
do you want me to do
what is with this this looking
impossible to POG Rafi here for that
cause the church is up there where the
hell am i I guess I just oh that's right
I got a curve all the way down cuz all
the path mmm hi I didn't even notice
either really a sneaky smooth good okay
so all the paths they converge down on a
come this is not the convergence points
this is dead end of the Mona Oh
yep just edit gravity crap
so
your page can be a good idea where I am
oh yeah baby boo
we're you add bugbear
we're dyin Oh
well this beautiful also terrifying
hello who are you
entry from the testimony of Boris W five
year old boy possibly exposed to the
unknown force caused the death of 12
people whadda me or complex 30 I've seen
you in my dream you asked me about the
same thing you're asking about right now
the same man was standing behind you
lorises no one standing behind me no
one's there but there's definitely
someone standing behind you
you're wrong dr. Gregor at Han know
which this man is asking me to tell you
that in the orange light the world is
more beautiful and as I asked you to
take a look at chamber number 7 section
22 how do you know all this Boris did
your father work in our department no
Gregor you son of a [ __ ] I've seen it
with my own eyes I'm a five-year-old by
the way I've seen you talking to people
and God died I've seen their skin
burning there aren't being Quinten I've
seen the nightmares done you playing in
their bridge do you want anything no one
knew about it do you think nobody
survived here shown us at the end the
entry that little kid sure showed him I
was uh thousand thing so the bridge must
be relatively new
die don't die don't die don't die don't
don't come to go down and don't die okay
thank you it's got to be the bridge down
here somewhere anywhere come on baby
give it to me that's it wait where was
that no okay yeah about where I thought
it was okay
Bridge should be just yeah Oh go faster
I don't have a lot of time left you have
to hurry oh you're goddamn right way
find me or I'll unleash hell upon you
okay geez Wow you meet a little boss
here I can only go so fast remember I
can only sprint in sudden bursts so what
does this mean what if what did that
mean like find me or all unleash hell
why what does that mean who are you
why am i helping you or am i stopping
you why am I here I walked through one
town and I got over here Who am I
my Boris I mean I think just judging by
that one whimpering scene I guess I'm a
little I'm a girl maybe not a little
girl but I don't know
I don't know if that was just like a oh
crap oh so cool oh so cool it's like the
final climb up to the last destination
we're the bong and so cool I really do
wonder if there was like only a specific
order that I could have possibly gone
through this but I felt like I had free
roam over the entire location so cool oh
this might be the end here I'm coming up
on the end
which you'll see in the next episode
don't you love cliffhanger endings yes
you absolutely do don t you lovely
lovely Zout there so thank you everybody
so much for watching I'm gonna finish
this up maybe in the next one you unless
I'm about to die which I'm gonna finish
up right now then so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye